this is peach fuzz panton's 2024 color
of the year it'll make headlines but
we're not going to talk about it a lot
in this video because selling colors is
not how the company makes money it also
doesn't make money selling paint or
color mixing Machinery or even color
itself what Pantone sells is something
much more abstract a promise of
uniformity so that the color peach fuzz
look the same whether it's printed out
on a billboard or a ceramic mug this
whole idea that you can sell consistency
is relatively new it's the brainchild of
this guy Lawrence Herbert aka the king
of color this is the economics of
Panton New Jersey 1956 recently
graduated chemistry major Lawrence
Herbert joined a small printing company
called Pantone as a part-time printer at
the time product packaging was less
consistent now we're used to seeing
products come in identical packaging
like all these blue Modello boxes but
panton's President says it didn't used
to be that way back when everything was
done over the phone it's really
difficult to say hey that's a it's kind
of like a cherry W but not as bright but
maybe slightly darker it's really hard
to actually convey that message for
example see these two camera boxes the
yellow on the right is brighter than the
one on the left codc says customers were
more likely to buy the lighter Yellow
Boxes logically thinking that the darker
boxes were older and therefore contained
older film customers didn't know that
the difference in color was due to the
fact that the boxes were printed at
different factories Each of which mixed
their own versions of Kodak yellow
Herbert recognized this was a problem as
he worked his way up the ranks at Panton
he became known for his expertise in
color chemistry and when he bought the
company in 1962 he had an idea to change
it from a printing company into
something entirely different that could
solve kodak's problems his team created
a set of formulas so every Factory
printed the packaging in the same color
for a lot of companies color is part of
their brand identity there's Tiffany and
they have that specific blue and it's
very important because we say oh that's
Tiffany blue we see the box and we go oh
you got me a Tiffany ring 67 years after
Herbert joined the company Pantone has
developed these formulations into over
10,000 colors so no one actually owns
color what we have is the IP of the
Panton color system which is a
collection of colors that we have
selected for its not just its beauty but
its reproducibility across different
formats matching colors across formats
is harder than it sounds but it's vital
for companies they may have um a color
in mind that they want to make sure that
can be reproduced across different
materials that they may be presenting
color whether it could be from U their
clothing line all the way to the
storefront all the way to the internet
representation on the website so say a
company wanted the same color on its
packaging and its magazine ads the ink
might look one way on cardboard and
another way on glossy paper so panone
would have to provide slightly different
formulas to make the colors look exactly
the same for example the cardboard
formula would be adjusted to a matte
absorbent slightly textured surface
while the formula for magazine paper
would be altered to account for the
shiny finish to ensure all colors look
the same Pantone has a rigorous Quality
Control process the company uses a tool
called the spectr photometer to compare
the same color on different surfaces so
Pantone would analyze reflected light
from the materials and generate a number
value based on that color then they'd
compare it to the number for the color
in their official index if the data
doesn't match they'd have to reformulate
yeah basically someone's out there you
know checking these cards to make sure
that the fabric that we've dyed are
within a certain Delta e difference
meaning that the color is consistent one
by one and it's highly it has to be
highly accurate Panton has done color
testing for over 10,000 colors which it
compiles into these color guides like
this 1964 version with which cover the
whole gamut or range of colors logged by
the company there are dozens of
different versions of the guide books
some are even made specifically for
certain companies about half of our
Revenue comes from the physical uh
guides that we have because there are so
many different formats of it they can
cost about $700 for this Essentials kit
to about $99,000 for a set of color
display Towers Panton says the guide
books generate the most Revenue it sells
them to designers marketers and artists
annually each year they're updated with
new colors your book is exposed to air
and it can oxidize and then what you see
in your book can visually change when
you look at it so then you won't
accurately know if that's the exact
color that you are looking for so for
that reason it is important to keep
getting fresh books so that you can view
them accurately Penton says the other
half of its Revenue comes from its
Consulting and Licensing and Digital
Services businesses Universal Studios
approached Pantone for the 2015 movie
Minions asking them to make a new yellow
it made this banana inspired Hue and
standardized it for the franchise banana
uh companies can trademark specific
colors so you can't say make and sell
your own competing products using
Tiffany blue but when it comes to all
the other colors in panton's guide books
so those who you know get their hands on
the color of course they can use the
color um but when we're communicating
colors between different people and this
is where the panone IP comes into handy
because can refer to a specific shade or
hue of a color through its name well the
majority of panton's Revenue comes from
those branches its well-known marketing
campaign might be what makes it a
household name 2024's peach fuzz is
inspired by warmth and Heat feeling a
panon spokeswoman said they anticipated
increased interest in self-care in the
next year which they felt the shade
represented we want to make sure that
our community of creatives and designers
you have a conversation about color
every year um at least once a year after
nearly 5 Decades of ownership Lawrence
Herbert's family sold Panton to x-rite
in 2007 the company makes color
measurement tools which help to cement
panton's status as a color Authority
just 5 years later x-r was acquired by
the danare corporation a life sciences
and Technology conglomerate in October
Panton and x-r spun off from danir with
11 other companies into a newly traded
company ver Alto Corp while Lawrence
Herbert could have never predicted
panton's Evolution his idea was a leap
forward for the marketing industry and
the World of Color and as products
advance from physical to digital Panton
scope will have to keep evolving when it
comes to color we want to make sure that
you know it's always going to be
consistent no matter where you are
whether it's in digital format where we
can continue to expand on that those
products and services or in different
types of physical format to help by our
customers and clients find the right
color and be able to execute those
colors the way that they want it to
[Music]
be